what do you think of when I say climate
change do you think big picture or if
something that starts I live in London
at a one-bedroom flat I share I have a
car I fly a number of times a year every
day I like to think I'm pretty you know
aware but for the next two weeks I'll be
finding out how good I really am how big
is my carbon footprint can I live a
low-carbon life and will it make a
difference what will my challenge reveal
about the choices we face and the impact
[Music]
to help me get a handle on my lifestyle
this is Mike he's an expert in carbon
footprints hello humankind has tripled
its energy consumption in just the last
50 years my generation has never known
any difference the science says we need
to almost have our carbon emissions by
2030 and cut them to zero by 2050 so
Mike's come to analyze my life the home
I live in it's tough if you're renting
the food I eat these king prawns
disaster and the way I travel around
it's belching out carbon dioxide
unfortunately it's not good news
the average UK person has a carbon
footprint of about 13 tons of carbon
dioxide equivalent per year okay and I'm
afraid to say you are roughly 50% more
than that 50% yeah just before you beat
yourself up too badly there's some good
news in some areas of your life and
there's some areas that we can talk
about the UK average is not necessarily
a good place to be either so I'm 50%
over what is already far too high
correct for the average person travel
which mainly boils down to driving and
flying is about a quarter what to do
roughly speaking and for you it's nearly
a half all right so so and the killer
for you as you're flying and afraid okay
my calculator that I am it roughly 21.7
tons of carbon dioxide equivalent a year
that puts me just shy of double the UK
average of 13.1 tons less than the US
but more than China food and travel are
my biggest emitters I take five or six
return flights a year and drive around
120 miles a week while I only eat meat
twice a week I don't pay much attention
to where my foods come from finally Mike
priced in the comm footprints of things
I can't control such as how the
government spends my taxes the challenge
for you is to knock two thirds off your
comfort
prynt 2/3 yeah which I take you from 50%
more than average to half of average
half of the average UK person half of
the average UK purse if everybody did
this over the next ten years and if the
whole kind of infrastructure of the of
the country also moved in the right
direction as well we would honestly be
able to say we are leading the world
towards the kind of change that we need
to see to stay within 1.5 degrees I
really hope you enjoy it I can't wait so
I need to keep my carbon footprint to
around 6 tonnes it's a big ask
it will mean living on a vegan diet
buying no air freight of food and making
packed lunches every day I'll have to
keep my gas and electric to a bare
minimum
glad it's summer and ditch my petrol car
completely whatever the weather gross so
for two weeks I'm borrowing an electric
car
they're so smooth so quiet on the road
electric is clearly greener but it's not
a carbon zero option the carbon
footprint of manufacturing a car like
this is huge and much in the electricity
used to charge it still comes from
fossil fuels not to mention the cost a
model like this starts around 27,000
pounds so though it's all well and good
me borrowing one for a couple of weeks
to do this challenge for many people
only one just isn't achievable and then
there's my diet some big changes to what
I buy good for some good vegan food and
importantly where it's from air
freighter dude is a big no the general
rule is that if it's durable enough to
have survived a boat journey it's almost
certainly been shipped so apples oranges
bananas etc are all fine
anything with a thinner skin and assure
to life is not these grapes I would
normally buy but they've come all the
way from India almost certainly been on
a plane so I'm gonna buy strawberries
from the UK instead but when time and
money are tight how practical are these
choices when I think about food and
fruit and veg and where it's come from I
couldn't tell you I really couldn't tell
you weekly shop is definitely budget amy
Downs lives in Yorkshire with her fiance
Luke and their two-year-old son Harry I
think you've got a lot of money you've
got the space the room to breathe to be
able to not have to think about or I'm
trying to knock ten pound off my food
budget we need something that is cheap
and quick she's concerned about climate
change and has agreed to let Mike
analyze their family's carbon footprint
he's not going to persuade me to get rid
of a car okay so let's have a look at
this fridge what do we got first up we
have to meet total carbon disaster beef
on the plus side an alternative source
of protein fantastic peanut butter we
get through a lot of bagged salad it
ends up thrown away okay so that's the
issue with fruit and veg is to make sure
that you eat what you buy here is your
family's
carbon footprints it's probably not
surprising that you're maybe a little
under the average since one of your
family is only two years old the dance
family have a carbon footprint of thirty
two point nine tons 11 per person
although their electricity bills are
low-impact and they don't take any
flights for them their food is the
biggest emitter lots of high carbon
meets air freight adverse and food waste
all contributors would you ever have a
meal without meeting it yes so there's
some really clear-cut science on this
the most important thing in terms of
what you eat is to cut down on the meat
and dairy and especially the beef and
lamb so beef and lamb with the highest
carbon meats because sheep and cows burp
up methane which is a really powerful
greenhouse gas yeah and then sort of
below that is pork and then below that
again is chicken but still a high carbon
form of protein we don't really think
about the carbon footprint because we
just think about what fruit is cheap but
actually from what you've explained how
the fruit and veggie meat impact our
carbon footprint we could just as easily
still keep going to that cheap
supermarket
it's just picking the right things while
we're there having Harry and another one
in the way what on earth are they going
to do when they get to my age and
anything we can do to reduce the
pressure on them now is the time that we
need to be doing it
back at home I was sticking to my low
carbon budget some things I was enjoying
back to work today
and overnight I've made myself some
vegan oats for my breakfast others not
so much so it's really unseasonable cold
today I kind of really want to put the
heating on but I can't and I won't
so I'm opting for an extra jumper and I
was learning that a low-carbon lifestyle
takes some planning really really late
for work today
but I need to make I need to make my
lunches I don't really have time for an
upcoming weekend away would put me to
the test I'm halfway through my
challenge we've been invited to a
wedding in the north of England normally
I'd have driven but instead we're going
to take the train
so I'm just back from that wedding in
the north of England I'm feeling a
little disheartened a bit frustrated I
think I probably completely blown the
budget that might gave me one there was
no vegan options at all at the wedding
to the venue was in the middle of
nowhere to where to get a lot of taxis I
guess it just shows that when you live
in a city it is quite easy to make green
choices in other parts of the country
it's not always the case and that
affects a family like the Croesus a
family of four who like their gadgets
live in a rural village and take a
number of foreign holidays a year
at work dad Rowan manufactures parts
many for the Renewable sector so we're
making components for hydrogen fuel
cells which is a clean way of generating
electricity but outside the office it's
not always as easy to be green I fear
the worst we're certainly not the
greenest family but I'm not sure that
many people are Mike again the bearer of
some bad news the craziest carbon
footprint was sixty point four tonnes of
carbon dioxide equivalent over the
average for a family of four while they
have a well insulated house and thus low
energy bills like me it was their diet
and flying that really pushed them up
they also had a higher than average
footprint relating to the stuff they buy
so clothes gadgets furniture and
appliances carbon impact and something
you consider honestly I don't think we
fight particularly regularly I suppose
we do I'll be honest if flying is
problem then I'm not sure yeah I think
that one would be difficult to change
there's no way around it flights are a
massive emitter just for return flights
to Hong Kong emit more carbon than the
average UK person uses in an entire year
the altitude makes it especially
damaging but at least there's some good
news you take up much more than plane as
about three times the carbon footprint
so you know you be you be this wage
should be out like like here if you were
flying first-class okay yeah well that's
something people like us don't change
it's a massive problem yes absolutely
it's not effect problem it is an issue
that we've created and it's up to us to
resolve it the mushrooms they're below
cool did you have a look and then
there's the stuff they buy there's a
carbon footprint in the manufacture of
any new I
Tim but how easy will it be for mum and
dad to convince teenagers Evie and Tom
to give up their upgrades I feel it's
just standard like you see all your
friends are there and so you want as
well you want to be involved with what
they're doing if I were to say that
that's really bad for the planet to do
that how does that make you feel I don't
feel as if that is a big thing but if
it's necessary because if you don't get
a new phone every once in a while then
your one's just gonna become outdated
it's not the only thing they seem
reluctant to give up at first I need me
every day at least a meal you know
sometimes too and it's not good do you
think that's something you could change
all you think of that is no way if I
tried I probably could but I don't want
but look at their faces when they saw
their impact laid out having had a look
at this if you can name one thing that
you would change what's it gonna be I
think it would be long-haul flights
definitely dire definitely
[Music]
the end of my challenge eating out can
have a high carbon footprint so I'm
celebrating with a vegan dinner party at
home and I'm do one last chat with Mike
we're meeting at a carbon zero house
some final inspiration this is what our
future could look like all the materials
of the house are very low carbon it's
recycled timber on the roof up here
we've got the solar panels we've
actually got no fuel bills at all
we don't expect every house in the UK to
be like this but we do think that every
house in the UK could go some of the way
towards this a far cry from my London
flat the what impact did my challenge
have broadly I think I brought it down
enormous Lee there was things I found
really really easy aerated food massive
one I mean that was just so so so easy
for me to change but I actually really
enjoyed experimenting with vegan recipes
um I'm not sure I'm gonna go full full
100% vegan in my life because it was the
small things I found quite hard it's
really difficult for me to say that I'm
never gonna fly again but it has really
opened my eyes it's all about
proportions you don't need to go extreme
you don't need to cut out every single
bit it's a big education job that needs
to be done because we've got to make
these changes in 30 years it's not it's
really not that much time no it's really
and you say 30 years I mean you know it
sounds like oh well maybe we could put
it off for 25 years and then absolutely
not you know we need to start on this
now doing something with a high carbon
footprint needs to look as weird as
letting your dog poo in the street what
happens if we don't ah let's not even
talk about it
be blunt you know will the world still
be at peace if we don't get on top of
this with such a powerful species and
now right this generation these few
years now are the moment in which we
need to just radically change the way
that we think about our relationship
with the planet and the way that we've
never had to before
absolutely everything we do has an
impact I've learned that while cutting
your carbon isn't always easy it's
definitely possible
there are simple winds which are
achievable for all families and much of
it is about changing our mindsets it's
educating at all levels and this has
been an education for me we are hitting
a point where if we don't change soon
we're really going to do some huge
damage crucially I've learned a
low-carbon life isn't a worse life and a
low-carbon world is one worth fighting
for
[Music]
you